[Music]
on this Thursday night a new investment
in electric batteries this is a historic
and transformative announcement billions
in public money lured a Swedish battery
maker to Quebec will the gamble pay off
it has never made batteries at Large
scale Seeking Justice for Joyce
eschequan I felt like I was watching a
murder what's changed three years after
her story highlighted racism in a Quebec
Hospital
back to Mast species hospitals brace for
a season of sickness
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
thanks to another injection of billions
in public money a Swedish company that
makes batteries for electric vehicles
has chosen to build its new plant in
Canada North volt is being promised 2.7
billion dollars in subsidies from the
Canadian and Quebec governments as part
of a concerted effort to lure companies
to Canada by matching incentives offered
by the United States stalantis and
Volkswagen have already been promised
about 30 billion dollars to build EV
battery plants in Ontario there are
questions about where the costly subsidy
arms race is headed Tim Sargent has our
top story tonight
foreign
it's the kind of deal that gets Federal
and provincial political leaders all
revved up a seven billion dollar
investment to build a massive battery
making plant for electric vehicles this
is a historic and transformative
announcement but at Northfolk we don't
stand still so we're bringing our
Ambitions to Canada the Swedish Company
North volt hopes to start building its
gigafactory for Lithium-ion batteries
just outside of Montreal it's the
largest single private investment ever
made in Quebec but there's a lot of
public financing behind the deal
subsidies in the forms of loans and
grants from the federal and Quebec
governments could reach as much as 4.6
billion dollars what is important is
that we're building an industry the
future of plant will be constructed on a
footprint of 170 hectares the equivalent
of more than 300 football fields
Northville chose Quebec after first
looking at almost all 50 states South of
the Border at full capacity North volt
is hoping to produce enough batteries to
power up to 1 million electric vehicles
a year but critics warn reaching that
goal won't be easy Northfolk has been in
this business less than one decade and
there's a lot of competition for more
experienced electric battery makers
northvolt
um has only barely begun to make
batteries it has never made batteries at
large scale
and this is the very largest scale
lawmakers and others pushing for a
Greener economy insist now is the time
to make these Investments groundbreaking
is scheduled to begin by early next year
with the first batteries coming out of
the plant in 2026 North bolt says the
entire Factory should be in full
production by 2028. Tim Sergeant Global
News Montreal
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
met with his Indian counterpart in
Washington today prime minister Justin
Trudeau says he's sure Lincoln would
bring up what he calls Canada's credible
allegation that Indian agents were
behind the killing of a Canadian sick
leader turia isri reports
America's top Diplomat is hosting his
Indian counterpart it's a pleasure to
welcome my friend and colleague U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken met
India's minister of external Affairs at
the state department we thank the U.S
for all they supported the G20 Summit
but it's Canada that's hanging over
their meeting
while they were quiet in front of the
cameras there are concerns being
expressed behind the scenes three
sources told Global News Canada's allies
were shocked by the decision to go
public and are deeply concerned about
how it will affect the relationship with
India last week prime minister Justin
Trudeau revealed Canada has credible
intelligence Indian agents may be linked
to the killing of sick leader Hardeep
Singh Niger Trudeau says he's certain
blinken raised the issue with the Indian
external affairs minister yes the
Americans have been
with us in
speaking to the Indian government about
how important it is that they be
involved in following up on the credible
allegations the White House would not
comment what I will say however is that
we have consistently engaged with the
Indian government on this question and
have urged them to cooperate despite the
close relationship between the U.S and
Canada this South Asia expert believes
it has limits it's a tough
spot is in and then it needs to balance
its close alliance with Canada with a
strategic partnership with Indiana
boosting that partnership is a major U.S
foreign policy goal as Washington courts
India as a counterweight to China the
U.S will draw a line because of who the
target of this allegation is this is not
a rogue State since the allegations
emerged Canada's allies have appeared
muted in their response as Western
countries weigh their own interests and
whether it's worth it to pick a fight
with India
Global News Ottawa
an indigenous woman who live streamed
her final hours in a Quebec Hospital
documenting how she was ignored by staff
and insulted with racist taunts is being
honored tonight what happened to Joyce
eschequan caused outrage three years
later her family and Community are still
working to ensure what happened to her
is never repeated here's Mike Armstrong
for days you never forget and for the
Leonard native friendship Center this is
one Joyce eschequan's video was first
seen by her friends on Facebook but then
spread quickly the first time I saw the
video I felt like I was watching a crime
and my first reaction was to call the
police
it's the first thing I did after I saw
the video was to call the police because
I felt like I was watching a murder
that's writhing in agony it's also how
she's treated when she was admitted a
nurse identified as Shaquan on her chart
as a drug abuser in withdrawal she
wasn't as Shaquan had gone to hospital
with stomach pains and would die two
days later of a buildup of fluid in her
lungs
that would happen after staff insulted
her in the video laughing and telling
her she was better off dead and only
good for sex
coroner who investigated the case was
asked if eschequan would have been
treated differently and survived if she
had been white she said yes and that
racism and prejudices led to her death
there will be a March outside the
hospital where eschequan died to
commemorate this day but also to
recognize a legacy as shaquan's video
gave indigenous peoples and women in
particular something to point to because
in the past too often if they complained
about how they were treated they weren't
believed with this video it was
something that was concrete that can say
that you're not alone and that you
weren't just imagining it
trust in the Health Care system has an
impact on health indigenous people are
less likely to go to hospital if they're
sick and that often compounds problems
that leads to a situation where you can
have 15 years difference of life
expectancy between indigenous people and
non-indigenous people now he's usually
there but ashokan's husband isn't
attending the vigils in her memory this
year a family member says instead he's
chosen on this day to remember privately
with his children Mike Armstrong Global
News Joliet Quebec
a judge in Saskatchewan has granted an
interim injunction to stop a government
policy about pronoun use at school the
decision pauses the requirement for
parental consent when children under the
age of 16 want to use different names
and pronouns lawyers argued the policy
violates the Charter of Rights and
Freedoms and could lead teachers to out
or misgender children at school the
province's lawyers say the policy has
been misinterpreted Premier Scott Moe is
recalling the legislature to pass
legislation protecting parents rights
Health Canada has approved an updated
covid-19 vaccine from Pfizer the one
dose vaccine targets a sub-variant of
Omicron and is authorized for use in
people six months of age and older
regardless of their covid-19 vaccination
history as winter approaches British
Columbia's government is bringing back
mandatory mask wearing in health care
settings
but starting next week on October 3rd
we're going we're going to be putting
back in some of the measures to make
sure that we're doing our best to
protect people who are most vulnerable
in those settings
healthcare workers visitors and
volunteers will be required to wear
masks in patient and Resident care areas
visitors to Long-Term Care Homes will
also be required to mask in common areas
The Province says people will be
stationed at Health Care entrances to
screen for symptoms of respiratory
illnesses
in the Netherlands three people have
died after a lone gunman opened fire
inside a Rotterdam apartment and a
University Hospital
suspect has been arrested police say he
was a student at the same Medical
University the gunman shot and killed a
39 year old woman and seriously injured
her 14 year old daughter who later died
the suspect then went to the teaching
hospital and fatally shot a 46 year old
teacher
in the U.S the first public hearing got
underway and the Republicans impeachment
inquiry a President Joe Biden
Republicans say their inquiry is focused
on whether Biden was involved in or
benefited from his family's foreign
business dealings including those of his
son Hunter Biden the White House calls
it extreme politics at its worst
Brittany Rosen explains what this is all
about
for years President Biden has lied to
the American people the accusations
center around Biden's alleged ties to
his son's foreign business dealings in
Ukraine and China during his time as
vice president the bidens and their
Associates created over 20 shell
companies most of which were creative
when Joe Biden was vice president and
raked in over 20 million dollars now
what were the Biden selling to make all
this money
Joe Biden himself Republicans say
they've uncovered an overwhelming amount
of evidence showing the president abused
his public office for financial gain but
Democrats aren't convinced if the
Republicans had a Smoking Gun or even a
dripping water pistol they would be
presenting it today but they've got
nothing on Joe Biden do you all sell
them leaves where the committee heard
from multiple Witnesses most of whom
were picked by Republican
Representatives none of them has
first-hand knowledge of Hunter Biden's
business deals I do not believe that the
current evidence would support articles
of impeachment there were Executives who
asked Hunter Biden for help again not
yet any proof about any kind of
complicity of President Biden the
committee will determine if there are
sufficient grounds for the Full House to
consider an impeachment Thursday's
hearing comes less than 70 hours before
a likely government shutdown we are
reaching the point where it's going to
be really hard for the house and the
Senate to act on a piece of legislation
keeping the government open President
Biden spent most of the day in Arizona
notably giving a speech on the state of
democracy the White House is calling
this a political stunt slamming the
committee for holding impeachment
hearings as opposed to putting forth
efforts to avert a government shutdown
Donna all right Brittany Rosen in
Washington thanks tens of thousands
fleeing their homes coming up the
refugee crisis in Azerbaijan as a deadly
territorial dispute reaches a climax
there's a major development in the
conflict over nagorno-karabakh the
Region's Breakaway government has
announced it will dissolve itself and
the Republic will cease to exist the
territory is internationally recognized
as being part of Azerbaijan but has been
run by ethnic Armenians for decades
Azerbaijan launched a major military
offensive last week to reclaim full
control it's believed more than half the
population of one hundred and twenty
thousand have fled Canada is providing
2.5 million dollars in humanitarian Aid
Crystal gemancing Reports
they escape the fighting in
nagorno-karabakh but not the fear from
the very first moments of the war we
stayed in the basement of our neighbor
for several hours the mother of four
says her children were crying and she
was scared
[Music]
in the past week there's been a steady
stream of people leaving the region more
than 70 thousand ethnic Armenians are
said to have fled of course I am going
to leave
because
this place is too small for both of us
if they are here we have to live this
ethnic Armenian journalist is
documenting the fighting her videos show
cars and buildings riddled with bullet
holes and families in hiding Global News
has not been able to verify the date or
the location of the images the World
Health Organization says a third of the
population of the region has fled many
have little to nothing with them I think
right now given the uh given the cold
temperatures of nice emergency shelter
is absolutely crucial the Prime Minister
of Armenia accused Azerbaijan of ethnic
cleansing in the nagorno-karabakh region
an allegation azerbaijan's foreign
minister said we strongly condemn and
reject adding we call an Armenians not
to leave their places of residence and
to be a part of the multi-ethnic
Azerbaijan
Azerbaijan arrested the former head of
nagorno-karabakh separatist government
it followed What Azerbaijan called an
anti-terrorism military operation last
week in an effort to seize control from
the Breakaway government Armenia had
called on countries including Russia to
help Russian peacekeepers have been
deployed in the region since 2020 now
fighting its own war in Ukraine Russia
was accused of not answering the call
without help Armenian forces surrendered
their weapons and control the growing
humanitarian crisis caring for all the
people needing food water and shelter is
now of greatest importance
Crystal commencing Global News London
trading in shares of the Chinese real
estate giant evergrant have been
suspended after reports its billionaire
chairman is under police investigation
Bloomberg was first to report ever Grand
founder hoi Kayan once one of China's
richest men is being monitored by
Chinese police after he was taken away
earlier this month remains unclear what
crimes he suspected of committing
Chinese media also reports several
current and former Executives have been
detained the real estate development
company is thought to have close to 300
billion dollars in debt its stock has
fallen more than 80 percent since August
when it resumed trading after a previous
17-month suspension the company
defaulted in 2021 in many Financial
experts say that triggered China's real
estate crisis
still ahead what we can do to reduce the
impact of wildfires in Canada
[Music]
has never had as many wildfires as this
year Natural Resources Canada says more
than 220 of them are still out of
control most of them in western Canada
winter will give fire Crews a breather
but the focus now is finding ways to
avoid another record-breaking year nithu
garcha reports on how the way we fight
and manage fires is evolving
I just want to do a quick touch base
we've had a lot of movement a lot of
transition last couple days it's the
start of another busy day for the crew
on the Rossmoor Lake Wildfire I know
some people are new to the fire but if
you've been on the on the fire you know
that this area that we're in we get a
lot of variable wins Global News was
granted rare access to BC Wildfire Crews
at the end of July on this day they were
carefully planning and executing planned
ignitions to burn up excess Forest fuels
what I want to do is I want to remove
all the surface fuels because that's how
fire starts to spread if I take that out
of the way out of the equation I can
walk away from here being very confident
that my fire will not wrap around me
Canada is in the midst of the worst
Wildfire season it's ever faced with
close to 18 million hectares in golfed
Nationwide and with climate change fire
seasons will continue to accelerate
that's why fire ecologists like Robert
gray say we need to reimagine how we
think about fire we need to be doing
much more prescribed burning
strategically doing it around
communities is a really important place
to be doing it people they hear us say
that and they what do you mean you're
burning next to communities
prescribed burns are similar to planned
ignitions when managed properly it can
reduce dangerous fuel sources create
healthy forests and boost animal habitat
the other thing fire does is it releases
all the nutrients that are stored in the
dead material experts want this approach
to be significantly expanded especially
since these Burns can act like fences to
fire movement if you have a lot of
fences on the landscape if you're just
slowing down fires it buys time for the
weather to change it buys time for
suppression resources to get there and
eventually you'll start to see fire size
shrink
that is very much the hope of those on
the front lines these wildfires aren't
just affecting our forests that are
affecting families and communities it's
just becoming a part of our lives here
in British Columbia and really across
the world
in our report on the new reality we
learn about
benefit biodiversity and reduce the risk
of wildfires
thanks nitu
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Toronto which happens to
be where the winning ticket for last
night's record-breaking 68 million
dollar Lotto 649 jackpot was sold
they're still waiting for the winner to
come forward so just a bit of advice
check your tickets thanks for watching
bye-bye
[Music]